yo tout le monde sait ce qu'on dit
aujourd'hui ma voix va mieux enfin un
petit peu mieux d'ailleurs va tout de
suite mettre un petit j'ai tellement
dégueulasse
donc aujourd'hui sur the interest in
town of mr doc fiche 1
donc le canard poisson what the fuck et
c'est parti on commence
est ce que c'est j'avais commencé un
juriste est comme ça voilà une fête de
canard ouais ouais j'ai petit ver de
terre
ouais super g un [ __ ] d'hippocampes
accule tête de singe ce qui fait
aujourd'hui on mélange les animaux voilà
c'est parti un cochon avec un corps
d'araignée un coq avec un corps
d'abeilles avec qui fait dans ce total
war ridicule et ce qui compte avoir une
copine afin d'asseoir et non c'est pas
possible non je ne pense pas et un
cochon avec une tête de loup oui montage
est totalement ridicule une mouche avec
une un accord de mouches remercions
incroyable et art lui aussi fait une
danse un peu on va chasser la grenouille
j'étais un message officiel des votants
france roland dhordain chaussettes
gauche parcelles
tout ça est bien trop bizarre à mon goût
exceet oui j'écris jixi j'existe cette
boîte de nuit très bizarre oh non
pauvres petits canards seul dans le noir
le soir what pas d'accord c'est un as
mais gaston maulin
qu'est ce que tu vas te faire il il va
vous met dessus pour la peine je vole la
revue les flèches
as tu vas pas revenir de l'autre côté tu
achetais picore la tête à eau la lune à
l'étude
aulas lunel by all à toutes les filles
devant leur écran mon père c'est trop
alors que nous les mecs on en a
absolument rien à [ __ ] oui c'est la
dure loi des deux du million et du pas
mignon a selon le sexe très bien bon
alors est ce qui va se passer à la il ya
plus de trottoirs d'accord donc je suis
quelqu'un qui va dès qu'il est tombé
dans le vide non mais j'ai pas envie de
tomber dans le vide
allez salut what what
pourquoi des toilettes pourquoi il ya un
pas c'est quoi ce délire
est ce que quelqu'un s'était élevé
contre ces toilettes et les a lancés par
la fenêtre
non ceci n'est pas possible non d'accord
très bien et je peux aller de l'autre
côté non bon je rentre avec des gens
super bizarre encore de voir dans ces
[ __ ] mais c'est quoi ce délire
lorsqu'on m'a dit mettez la danse du mec
juste la super nul
j'ai mal fait à la tête ok
c'est absolument ridicule si j'avais une
carabine
j'aurais tiré j'aurais tiré
j'aurais tiré sur la chaîne pour les
plus musique qu'ils arrêtent de dans ses
bottes de pluie tarde psychopathe zèle
pour ckoi bombe à exceet je m'en veux de
nouveau
et qu'est ce que c'est un va me faire à
je ne m'y attendais pas pourquoi tu me
fais ça hein pourquoi est ce que c est
ce qu c'est un truc en boucle donc
largué au bayer ou alors est-ce qu il ya
quelque chose à faire dans ce jeu 1
ou alors c'est juste un jeu tellement
étrange ya juste des gens qui dansent
avec d'accord qui ne va pas avec leur
tête un donc et trouvera encore
s'envoler
oui est ce qu'on va voir des toilettes
sur la droite un b sur la gauche
oui qu'est ce que ça veut dire est ce
que c'est une nouvelle constellation la
constellation du balai dans les chiottes
peut-être oui il bouge ça bouge comme un
[ __ ] de poissons en l'air regardez
regardez on compare deux semaines
désormais la première scène celle de
notre petit canard
et bien dans la deuxième scène un
poisson qu'ils mangent
est ce qu'il ya une différence
laissez-moi dans l'année 10,6 à on ne
peut pas s'en aller de la soirée [ __ ]
allez je me remettrai jamais ça dans ce
coin c'est du caca
vous donnez moi puisque j'en vois deux
ans bon vieux skis et mordre ou c'est
faux
on remarquera quand même que la danse de
notre canard et moins ridicule que celle
de tous les autres
un quoi si elle reste quand même
ridicule à temps
je crois que c'est à peu près tout au
niveau des danses un attendait non au
nom au nom james est évidemment vécu là
on peut finalement se diriger vers la
sortie un prendre un peu de repos
c'est dans ces deux épisodes je vois sur
et attend non non voilà esquive
alors oui il en a rien à [ __ ] quoi tu
pourrais le regarder comme ça toute la
nuit ils diraient juste ça s'allume and
tu vas t'asseoir à côté de moi ah non ça
va ya il ya une sorte de liquide par
terre à haccourt canard court et qu'est
ce qu'elle veut mais regardez la elle
je m'en vais je vous propose qu'on se
quitte sur ce super voyages inter balle
étoilé talent à dans le dans l'espace ah
et puis c'est toi tu faisais les
claquettes c'est exactement ça on se
souvient tous de nouvelles vidéos tu
serais désolé pour ce jeu voilà je fais
des excuses publiques à et je sais que
vous êtes content oui évidemment on va
essayer de faire des jeux qui durent
want to plant ancien que la durée de vie
de ce jeu est d'environ 30 secondes bon
j'essaie j'ai quand même pas mettre nue
je trouve on se retrouve un jour d'une
nouvelle vidéo chat monde puisse à
bientôt
portez vous bien et profitez bien de vos
vacances piece of common enfants
m